this morning in the wake of last week's
assault on the capital some of america's
biggest corporations are backing away
from politics in fact lawmakers
overall could be worried here more than
a dozen fortune 500 companies have
suspended
all political donations and at least one
actually wants the money back from
senators who claim that joe biden's
election
was a fraud political correspondent ed
o'keefe reports now
on what impact this could have on monday
hallmark cards company asked for a
refund from republican senators josh
hawley
and roger marshall who received a
combined 12 thousand dollars
the company says that the senator's
decision to vote to reject state's
certified electoral college results last
week
do not reflect our company's values
american express told employees monday
they're withholding donations from
lawmakers who voted to subvert the
presidential election results and
disrupt the peaceful transition of power
other major firms like goldman sachs
citigroup facebook
google and microsoft are going farther
saying they'll withhold
all political contributions from members
of both parties
chemical giant dow doing so for at least
the next two years
it's sending a ripple effect across all
these campaigns
because donald trump is radioactive
leslie sanchez is a republican
consultant and cbs news political
analyst
and said the corporate giving ban could
hurt many gop candidates
the question campaigns are asking
themselves is how long is this going to
last
and can they separate their campaign
from the larger
republican party and the aura that it
has but sanchez said that based on her
conversations with top government
relations executives
the giving ban is likely only temporary
six months
and nine months down the line they
expect those dollars to start flowing
again
these are going to be based on
individual relationships and not
necessarily the party as a whole
but cbs news political contributor
robbie mook a democratic party
consultant
thinks this is a bigger shift this is
part of a larger reckoning we're seeing
in our society
you know employees of these companies
really care
about what their leadership is doing
about what happens to this pac money
that they're donating
and we saw how this was transformational
in sports
and entertainment and i think we're
going to start to see it uh in corporate
america as it relates to politics as
well
corporate america is also facing
pressure when it comes to hiring
president trump's current and former
spokespeople
white house press secretaries often go
on to get high profile jobs in the
private sector
president obama's landed at mcdonald's
amazon
and united airlines forbes magazine
editor randall lane argues that those
that spoke for mr trump
will face a different landscape he says
if top companies hire them
his magazine quote will assume that
everything your company or firm talks
about
is a lie there's no way that we can look
at our readers
and say these are people we can trust in
the private sector now to give
accurate information in other fallout
the pga is distancing itself from
president trump announcing it won't play
the pga championship
at the trump golf course in bedminster
new jersey next year
other companies including airbnb best
buy and coca-cola say they're
reconsidering their political giving
cbs news is of course part of the viacom
cbs family we checked with our corporate
parent
spokesman said they had no immediate
comment on their political giving plans
gail okay
i was expecting an answer there but
thank you there certainly are
consequences
thank you very much ed o'keefe in an
exclusive interview you